most of you are not doing what you want
to do with your life because you're
worried about somebody else's opinion
normally your fucked-up mom or you know
your spouse or you know somebody very
close to you is [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
right so that's awesome for me but on
the flip side in the macro of me not
giving a [ __ ] when somebody leaves one
comment on an Instagram post like this
guy's a scam artist I'm like
strategizing how to fix that like it's
the most important thing that has ever
happened to me pulling from opposite
directions is like a bridge my friends
it is not something that you should be
scared of way many to many people think
it's a contradiction think it's a flaw
when you define what true intelligence
is it is holding opposite things in your
head and allowing them to push I love
that everything is easy to me we were
having fun beforehand I'm like what's
this thing I'm doing after Mikey no and
they're laughing they're like you didn't
read it I'm like I haven't read [ __ ] in
20 years I don't need to be prepared I
stay in my lane the reason I love doing
Q&A is if I don't know the answer to
your question I'll say I don't know the
answer to your question we are fronting
we are fronting in our society you need
to triple down quadruple down on who you
are and what you know and then you can
win when people ask me how do I prove
content one big breakthrough in my
community was when about six months ago
I said you know what you should document
instead of create it opened up so much
for so many when they realize wait a
minute right you need to be documenting
in your stories or in your vlog about
the journey of becoming an entrepreneur
not claiming that you're a 21 year old
life coach and pay me $5,000 a month and
I'll teach you how to [ __ ] live [ __ ]
you
[Music]